I'm about to connect a piece of the puzzle here that is like
wild on top of this. Okay. >> Oh no.
Oh no, dude. Oh my god. >> She actually has no This is
about to be the best moment of food shops life.
>> I think there's like a bunch of vlogs with Destiny.
Oh, Destiny like mentioned me. I don't I don't even know what
the [__] he's talking about.
Uh, hold on. I got to go find this screenshot now. Just like
a quick mention. I just have to laugh. It's like so desperately
trying to keep me like concerned or caring in any way.
It's very bizarre.
Oh sh Did Sya drop all his stuff? Wait, did
Oh, did Sya actually talk about the what happened on August?
Is it 18th 19th? Oh, sorry. I'm looking for this screenshot that
got sent to me. Oh, right here. What is this? Oh, right, right,
right, right, right.
Hold on. I I I might have to look into this a little bit more
just to cover it. Oh, one of the big memes is in the new filings.
Uh, Destiny, I read it and didn't see anything big. Unless you
mean maybe meets the secret witness who lives in Texas, the one
that just dropped today for 3 years. Actually unbelievable. The
filing meme ex-boyfriend impersonated her in discourse discord
correspondence he was having with Benell while pretending to
be Rose for 3 years. Actually unbelievable. Maybe I can talk
more about it in the future.
So, apparently,
by the way, I just I listen, I haven't thought about this, so
maybe I'll say something. Okay,
maybe. Yeah, I realize that Pepperjack, it's fine. Um, so apparently
Rose testified that she was being impersonated in those DMs.
Now,
I'm not a lawyer, but I do believe
swearing under oath that you distributed child is probably bad.
So, for one, that would be her testimony. No doubt. Right. No
doubt that would be her testimony.
For two,
didn't he just objectively lie his through his teeth about like
this being a close person that this was somebody he talked to
on the phone? You remember that when he first talked to Pixie,
he was like, "Oh, this is somebody I've talked on the phone like
so many times. It's actually like somebody I totally trust."
So, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. There's like all of that.
Yeah. And the other thing is is the unique picture that only
Destiny had of her only wearing the DG
t-shirt, right? She's sending him like a picture in a DG
How did How did that get taken?
How did So he he docked a minor he was receiving material of
and he's like, "Guys, it's okay though. The person talking to
me sending me the material of the minor, they were an adult.
It was just an adult sending me child, not a minor. I'm saved,
guys. I'm saved. I'm so saved right now.
What?
Uh, no. Total Jenny death. If you are 17 sending picture of you
as a child um as like a minor you I believe you can literally
be charged with I don't know how that works every time but I'm
pretty sure distributing
is something that can get applied to a 17-year-old especially
if they take like a year or two they still have the pictures
of them at 17 like like I think that's actually a big issue.
So
Yes. But it's way worse. Just remember, by the time this all
resolves, Pixie knows all of this and is just sitting on it to
keep drawing things out while some unbelievably horrible has
happened and is being let go on the background.
Uh, it was me who's Rose all along.
I just I want Did nobody ask him like, "Wait, who's the who's
the girl you doxed? Wait, who's the who's the girl?
This is the most insane loophole." Yeah, Kilo. It is. It is the
most insane loophole, guys. An adult sent me that child. I'm
I'm Scott I'm off scot-free, just so you know. That's absolutely
not absolutely not child there at all.
Uh we we'll see what happens. Maybe maybe it comes out that unbeknownst
to him, okay, at this time because he never once said this, right?
Never once said anything about this, but unbeknownst to him,
by the way, nothing saying he can't talk about this, can't say
these things, right? He has been perfectly happy to take stuff
from filings, even stuff that's sealed, and leak it. Why would
he not have been talking about this before it got filed? Oh,
maybe because he got in trouble before, possibly. Is that related
to Desty sending tapes without consent? It's not. That's the
funny thing is it's not Well, it kind of is in that they had
to depose the girl, right, to see when the date was to know like
to resolve that. Anyway,
I just thought or he So, he just doxed a 17-year-old or sorry,
a person who was 17 at this time who he thought was that girl
accidentally. I don't
there's so many things that don't make sense. Like the this story
doesn't hold together in like anyway,
but maybe maybe there's a way to bring it back after a while.
Rezling, thank you for the nine months. Appreciate it, buddy.
I think we had two gifties right before we started the stream
as well. Are we at three already? We are at two. Hold on a second.
We had Rezling, green pepper, riyle. Ah, I missed the Riyle one.
Just remind me, we're at like three already. We're at three.
Hold on. We'll keep reading here. What What else is there? So
Pixie kept this stuff in the background. I don't know that this
helps.
Pixie's like, "Oh, you sent my my to an adult instead of a child."
Okay. Uh, the you received was of the Oh, the person. You thought
it was of the person. So, you sent the vids before the law was
instated. Yeah. Well, I mean, the rose vids we always knew were
sent before the law was st like uh instated. We always knew that,
right? It was about one getting that on the record and then two,
I think uh honestly, I think this one was mostly just to
like hurt. I can't really think of anything else. Oh. Oh, man.
There's so many random little things around this that I might
pull up. Just give me a second. I got sent some other stuff here.
Hold on. Oh
yes, Cyber Cyber leaked the details of
where was where was not so Aerodite on what is this? August 18th.
What was the date again? The 19th of August. Why can't I see
it? The 18th of August. Where was Aerodite on the 18th of August?
Oh, okay. Hold on. Wait, wait, Riyle, you just sent these to
me absolutely disconnected from context. 17th. 17th. Gotcha.
Sorry, Ry. You sent me these. Like, I don't have the context
around this. So, you have to explain what the stuff you're sending
me is. I know the first things. Uh, so basically, and I don't
know if Cyber's insisting that like there's something else going
on here. Okay.
Oh, I didn't see that. You asked me. My
Okay. So, it was just really weird that
apparently there's like a Renfair that happened in
August. I can't remember if it was in Nebraska or Illinois.
happened to be at that same Renfair.
Rose was at that Renfair.
So like a random randomly in Augustite
and Rose happened to be in the same place. I Yeah.
And it's like
there's no way, right? There's no way. I'm not saying it's connected
at all. This is the thing I was telling you guys. It's like a
joke from It's like a joke from back
I think a couple weeks ago I was telling you guys this joke,
right? Like I was I was I was telling you that there's like a
joke about Kylo that we're I'm not like going to publish because
it doesn't mean something. But then we started memeing about
about it in the Discord. Okay. We started memeing it or memeing
about it in the Discord and this is like I'm never going to pull
this up but this is a picture of Rose. Okay. They just happen
to be at the same Renfair. Yeah. It was it was very goofy. Okay.
And like the the thing about this fair that's weird is it's probably
like a 15 to 20our drive from Florida.
No, I don't think Destiny was there. I don't think so.
Anyway, I'm just I'm like laughing about it cuz Sya posted it.
So, if he posted it, then I don't know. It's like it's out there
now. Cyber told me about this. Like I I'd known about this for
quite a while. It was just like, okay, I don't know. I can't
say anything happened here. It was just like very odd. It was
just like such an odd coincidence.
Yeah, it was such an odd coincidence. Wait, I hope Riyle didn't
just fool me into like saying what the coincidence was.
Hold on, hold on, hold on. Saba definitely talked about this,
right? How much does Sya talk about it? I hope I didn't leak.
I I don't think I leaked like anything crazy cuz I I want to
say like all of the stuff I'm pretty confident has been like
in terms of identities and stuff. Okay, he talked about it. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Oh, for a second. Riyle sent me like some screenshots
and I was like, "Oh, did I just get like fooled into talking
about it?" No, no, no. It's out there. Okay, it's out in public.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. No, these pics were all over socials,
I'm pretty sure, or something. I don't know.
They all got cleaned up. Yeah, Rose is this person. I'm just
I'm not going to pull I'm not going to pull it all. Yeah, it's
also all by the same photographer. Yes.
I'm not going to pull a bunch of this stuff up like further,
right? They end up in the same MDMA tent orgy.
Well,
yeah. Oh, I wish I'd been prepared. I just I got sent this and
I'm like, "Oh, well, if it's out there in public, I'll talk about
it."
Like, here's the thing.
I don't know when did Rose's identity get known. It might have
been right around this time. I don't know.
I don't know if there's like any reason to believe that Kylo
knew who she was at this point, but I again I it's just funny
that there's like a bunch of evidence of this. It's just like
a really weird mind that when we found it, it's like, wait, did
we just do we stumble on something crazy? And it's it's like
a crazy coincidence. I don't know. I don't know, man. When would
she have found out? Well, I assume she'd have found out at the
same time most other people would have. Oh, there's another thing
that connects to Kyla here, and I don't remember. Hold on, hold
on, hold on.
Oh, hold on. I I need Oh, hold on. Let me message somebody. Ah,
hold on. I need to I need to Photoshop somebody. Okay. Or Photoshop
something. I need to Photoshop somebody's
cuz this is like skitso. This is totally skitso. Okay. Oh god.
Oh god. Everything is becoming schizophrenic. Everything is becoming
schizophrenic.
I'm about to connect a piece of the puzzle here
that is like wild on top of this. Okay. Okay. I'm I'm really
really with some stuff. Hold on.
This is just funny. There's like I'm I'm like baiting you guys
so hard, but I think it's going to be worth it. Trust me.
Trust me when I say it will be worth it. I just got to I got
to censor some stuff out of
some screenshots here or else I can't I can't share it. though.
Give me a second cuz I don't even know if I shared this with
Cyber, which I should have at the time, but this was what I was
sent. And it was talking about Arerodite. Hold on. I need to
check with Cyber 2 really quickly. Hold on. I'm sorry. I'm like
I'm I I
like have been living my life mostly ignoring this stuff. Isn't
that Cyber? You tell me. You're watching. That time stamp's very
very conspicuous, isn't it? Now, that is that is total schizophrenic
rumor. Okay, that's total schizophrenic rumor right there. That's
my That's my bad.
Uh, soapbox, I think. So, he's saying that he was catfished by
a guy
who had direct He's basically catfished by the girlfriend. The
girlfriend must have been complicit in it because she's wearing
DG merch and pics she sent to Destiny that only Destiny had that
Destiny gave people to try to dox her, right? That is the That
is the picture by which they found her
Okay, I just have to I'm going to show this this one. So, this
stuff is all like confirmed. This is just true that Kyloin and
Rose happen to be at the same place at the same time. Okay, that's
that's confirmed. Now, here's Are you ready for like the skitso
part? I forgot somebody else told me about this and I just connected
it now.
And so, I'm taking a screenshot of a screenshot, but I also cut
out people's names. Okay, so Kyla apparently
did this on a straight like I I I'd heard this is a way that
they found that that Kiwi Farms had found this Rose person, right?
This is what I was sent was this was DMs between people. Did
hear a rumor that it was her loudmouth that gave KF the clue
to find Rose. Not intentionally. Yeah, what did you hear? That's
it. She said her name or something by accident, but I'm curious
to find where the rumor started. And the rumor is on August 22nd,
2025.
Wait, wait. What? Wait. So like I
I and like the idea would be before. So now I don't even know.
By the way, this is like not anything serious. I'm not making
like a serious allegation of anything. I'm telling you this is
pure innuendo like schizosphere stuff. That is just all
all rumors and stuff behind the scenes. I have like no allegations
that go with this. Who? Ardite. Yeah, this is referring to Aerodite
and but like
can you explain the lore here? Well, the lore is that Kyla
and this uh this rose person were at the same Renaissance fair
like
I don't know in August,
And they were they have pictures of themselves taken by the same
photographer at the same Renaissance fair.
Uh hold on. I'm just asking where it was because I don't remember
like the state. Just say the state. It's some It's some Midwest
state. So, like 20-ish 15 20-ish hours drive from Florida.
Uh, it could be that the case that her boyfriend talked to him
once or twice as her, but which means she didn't technically
lie, but it's a lie by omissions. Well, I mean, I I just don't
know how
I don't know how much it helps.
Was Kenosha. Oh, right. This is all out there because Kyla Kylo
was talking about it, right? Kylo was literally talking about
um
Kyla's talked about going to this Renf Fair. Sorry, just going
back to what you were saying there, Ethan Klein.
I think
on that front, I just don't know how that helps in any way.
How does that help in any way? It's still It's still a person
who told like somebody still told him that there was there. It
seems like the person in the pictures is still
and he had no idea it was the guy or the
I just don't understand how this helps. It's like, oh, there's
a brand new fact and it is still the all of the main criticisms
still apply that you didn't talk to this person. In fact, now
all you've revealed is you were obviously blatantly lying when
you said you talked to this person on the phone.
What's the new fact? I believe in the new in the new transcript
of I think the Rose person's deposition,
right? I think
that they
said they were that somebody else was impersonating them. Yeah,
it doesn't really do anything for the Pixie case. No, but I'm
just telling you in it doesn't really do anything for anybody
anywhere. This all like some goofy Rose's boyfriend was basically
Chris Hansen. Chris Hansen with actual
Don't forget that. Chris Hansen with actual
All right.
Chris Hansen wishes he could have uh that kind of that kind of
bait. That's like fishing with live bait. Okay, that's not allowed.
That's illegal. That's unethical. I don't know why DG Well, I
don't know why DG's trying to spin this as a win. I don't know
why Destiny is. And I'm just like, bro,
Like, wait, what?
You you you docked somebody wearing like a DG shirt. That's like
the person that everyone thinks is Rose. That's the person who
had the Only Fans account from all all for all intents and purposes.
Wait, what are we talking about here? What? What the [__]
are we talking that like whose name everything like align up
one to one?
I don't I straight up don't understand. Like, yeah, an adult
sent you these.
Uh-huh. That's That's best case scenario. An adult was like manipulating
this person into giving them the pictures they needed to maintain
the sherrod with you. Willie Maxo is so I have a feeling he might
come up with an apology video. That would be embarrassing.
I feel like if he's still friends with Nicholas, Nicholas would
totally caution him against that, right? Could you imagine if
Willie M came out, apologized, uh, soapbox society, things with
the 10 gifted. Let's go. Could you imagine if Willie Mack came
out, apologized, and then there was like a like he was arrested
or something.
Could you imagine that? Could you imagine how stupid Willie would
have to leave the internet, right?
I don't think he could apologize at this point. Anyway, I should
keep reading these logs. We haven't even gotten through them
yet. Uh, we've known this for 3 weeks is so much worse than me
just getting catfished. Desty, that's the What's the ETA on when
you can give us more than vague posting about it? Hm. I think
like two weeks. We filed a thing to have them correct their public
filings. If they don't, then we file for more sanctions, I think.
Shouldn't they get sanctioned for putting unverified statements
into the public record? Yep.
No. Wait, what?
Wait, what? Your initial complaint is not Wait, your initial
complaint is not just verified statements. What? Huh? That's
maybe that's insane.
Your initial complaint is like things you think you can reasonably
like in good faith prove.
It's It's not things that you have like factually known. I don't
I literally don't understand why your initial complaint would
only have like
I don't know why it wouldn't have like things you were told,
right? Like if somebody comes to you and says, "Hey, I think
this this person um
this person was like spreading your video to me." Right? If somebody
comes to Pixie and says that, she could put that in the thing.
Uh is it worthwhile to do that if she can't um if she can't substantiate
it at all or if it's like totally flimsy? No.
But yes. Yes. In signal. Yes. He's getting this from well or
I mean I guess or they can go into a whole thing where they start
saying something like I would expect them to go here where they
would start saying something like oh actually he was getting
videos of like multiple people right he was getting videos of
multiple people it wasn't her it was like other people but then
I would say there's no way to verify that or if that's true then
he should be able to share those videos right if they're from
a sex worker.
Shouldn't he be able to share those? And the the person's of
age. Shouldn't he just be able to share those videos? Am I crazy?
That's That's like uh That's crazy. That's um Shre. Okay, I don't
want to [__] around with that.
Anyway, we keep going. So, he thinks in two weeks he can start
saying some
Desi, can you give us some crumbs? Did you see anyone in the
sub or in here guess it correctly? What's the worst thing about
LA? I don't know. Wait, if I understand it correctly, this girl
was trafficked and Pixie is using her for fraudulent lawsuit
against Destiny 344. That would be crazy, dude. Wait,
hold on. She was being trafficked.
How does this help? Where's Where's the help? Am I Am I insane?
I don't see how this like makes him look better in any way. What
does this help with? Oh, it's bad that her identity was revealed.
Brother, YOU GAVE ALL THE INFORMATION THAT HELPED HER GET DOXED.
YOU ARE THE ONE WHO DOCKS THIS trafficking victim. What?
He is the one who provided all the key information to dox the
person.
He is the one who GOT HER IDENTITY BLASTED ALL OVER THE INTERNET,
but for his intervention, she might never have been found.
What are we doing?
Uh or I mean or or
look at this weirdass video Desty just posted on his Twitter.
Uh maybe I don't know. I'm just I'm just laughing. That would
be crazy, dude. Remember that KF and Jtock and Willie Mac and
everyone all happily and gleeully were posting this girl's docs
and videos and everything else all over the internet, too. Huge
thumbs up on that.
Wait, I posted her docs
where I think when Willie Mack posted the docs, they said, "Oh,
that's pretty insane. You shouldn't do that." But I think I I
think I acknowledged like seems like, you know, Destiny will
just lie unless people prove it and the the DJs will will go
do all that. Still shouldn't do it. But, you know, I understand
someone making that trade-off. Reminder, do could have just joined
with Destiny to actually just destroy the life of this solo person
who actually like
they could do both.
They could do both. Destiny still wronged this person like horribly,
which is why he admitted to doing so, right? Didn't he already
take credit for that? He did, in fact, Kendrick Lamar. That's
a great point. He actually took credit for doxing her. He said,
"Why? I helped dox her." Yes. Wait, where is that conversation
with Ellie B? Can anyone find me that that Twitter like that
big long tweet chain with Ellie? Hold on. I'll try to find it.
LeB again. And then it was uh Did I get this right? Hold on.
I'm looking for the LE thread. I want to go see that LED thread.
Oh, can I You guys know the one I'm talking about, right? It's
actually important. So, give me a second. Hold on. I can't I
literally can't find
I can't find the actual thread.
Oh, somebody found it. Maybe Kathy found it. Is this the one?
This is This should be the one, right? This should be the one.
Oh, also guys, uh sorry to the the Twitch gang. Okay. Sorry to
the Twitch gang. You guys are gonna have to head over to
kick.comjastk.
All right. kick.com/jastk if we're going to do full skitso. Full
skitso stream. Haven't done it in a while. I'm going to head
over to kick only for the rest of the stream. Okay. Good luck,
guys. See you over there in just a bit. kick.com/jk.
Also, I'll add up time on the timer in just a second. Let me
let me go grab this tweet. Let me switch things over. Boom. Boom.
Boom. All right. All right. Okay. All right. All right. All right.
Where was this Kathy tweet that he linked? Was it this one? It
was not this one. It's in the one where he basically asks Kathy.
He asks like why
he he basically says like why do you think I doxed her or why
do you think I help dox her? It's when she says you should go
to the cops with the evidence.
She says something along that, right?
Oh, no. It should be this thread. Wait, why isn't it this thread?
Hold on. Let me see here. It was in one of these arguments with
Ellie that he talked about like actually who do you think gave
the info to KF? We'll find it. Give me a second. Oh, I swear
to God. I swear to God he posted this. You guys remember this,
right? I'm not I'm not crazy. It was in one of those. Yeah, it
broke off into two reply threads. I'm trying to find the other
side of it cuz I swear to God this was said and it's like actually
it's just actually really funny that he was he was playing both
sides of this at the time. Oh, this rape uh was posted in the
e- rape defense squad channel. Hold on. Hold on. Somebody linked
it apparently. One second. Oh, yeah. Like, are you going to give
cop evidence to the cops? I have nothing to give them. Remember,
the only reason they even found Rose, this Rose person, was because
I posted the pics in chat to bait them into looking.
And so, he like he he plays both sides of this so transparently.
It's like actually hilarious. Remember that KF and Jay talk and
Willy and everyone all happily and gleefully reposting this girl's
docs and videos and everything else all over the internet. Uh,
right here. Uh, uh, who do you think?
Who do you think helped them find the rose person? Guys, who
do you think Who do you think posted those pics in chat and told
the Kiwi Farms, "Hey, take a look at this."
Think Destiny is having a manic episode on Twitter? Oh, entirely
Is that the tweet? Did you guys link me the tweet? I need Listen,
is Top Bronson watching right now?
I need a picture of me pondering the orb.
One second. I need a I need a a picture of me pondering the orb.
Okay,
tweet this screenshot.
Tweet. Tweet what? this screenshot. Sure, why not? Why not? Why
not just throw it out there? Give me a
Oh, no. I don't like that. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. I need
a better version of this. Hold on. Oh, that that's too skinny
to get put into Twitter correctly. Give me a second.
Mexican. Thank you. There you go. It's out there. Wait, you guys
were linking some tweets. Hold on. What are the tweets? What
are the tweet? I don't We're not going to spend very long on
this. Okay, we're not going to spend super long on this. Did
you see the de Laguna tweet I didn't want to post? Oh, send it
to me. Sure, I'll take a look. Oh, here it is. Yeah, here it
is. Here it is. Here's the post from back then. I have nothing
to give them. Remember, the only reason they even found the Rose
person was because I posted the pics in chat to bait them into
looking. Seems pretty stupid to do that if I thought she was
17. Huh. Wonder if any of them will spend even half the effort
looking for the child trafficker.
>> Wait, hold on. This is this recent.
Is this Wait, is this recent?
Wait, why are these two having like full-on Karen fights in the
street right now?
Like, are they actually just they're caring back and forth? That's
crazy. That's like uh this is like Anaka Kasparian. I don't know
which one's Anakasparian, but this is Anaka Kasparian and her
crazy neighbor. Okay, this is like the actual fight that's happening
right now. >> This is my best friend, Lauren Deuna. How
you doing? >> You came to Texas? >> I literally am
gangstalking her right now. I am gangstalking this wonderful
>> He's like literally slurring while while Yeah, he's
literally slurring his words while taking the video.
>> I work here. >> What a [__] weirdo.
Do you have anything you would like to say to the audience? >> Yeah,
you're freak. You're [__] >> Okay, cool. Anything
else? Thank you for joining us today. >> Thank you for
stalking me. >> You're a oneman. This is a oneman gangstalker
army right now. Okay, so thanks for hanging out. >> You
just keep making >> this is my best. >> What else
do you do? Just to be clear, I had zero idea she was here and
she just runs up to me with her phone and starts recording me
out of nowhere. So I take a video non-consential because why
not? It's in the street. Now you're taking a video of her walking
away.
I think
>> Okay. Why I need to be deposed? >> Do I really?
Are we recording each other >> Okay, cool. How are you
doing? And how is life in Texas? >> Uh, I'm going to go
to my boss. >> Okay. Be careful. Say bye. I'll see you
>> Why? Why are you following me? >> Cuz I'm bored.
I gangstalk in real life. >> You're a [__]
freak. You're
>> You are.
>> I mean, Rose.
>> True. Queen, stay safe. Be careful.
>> I I can't imagine how drunk he is that he thinks this
looks good for him.
Oh yeah, I'm a I'm a just because I I
of a minor that's that's makes you now. Okay, good one Lauren.
That's pretty bad faith of you, Lauren.
>> Yeah. So why I need to be deposed? >> Are we okay?
I just dude this it actually is like a like a an actual
very unlucky. friend Lauren Deaguna. How you doing?
>> I literally am gangstalking her right >> I am
gangstalking this wonderful lady. >> I work here. >> [__]
weirdo. Guys, I don't know what else to say. When you are the
average of your five best friends and all five of those friends
is Darius,
dude. I
It's just very bizarre. Very bizarre behavior from him. I do
wonder who's advising this guy at this point that's telling him
to continue doing this. Were these the tweets you guys were sending
me about the weird crash out happening?
Okay. Uh, no. Esports. I don't think that's true. I don't think
that's I don't think that's true.
He's Ethan Ralph. He really is Ethan Ralph. But thankfully, the
only women he's ever tried at any length to interact with on
the Sorry, the only people he's ever tried at length to interact
with on the internet are women. So you won't get the beat out
of him like uh Ethan Ralph. Yeah, it's very weird. It's very
very weird. No, no, no. Oh, the day.
So the day we Well, no, we found this quite a while ago. We found
this back in August. Alpha Kilo and we don't know that Aerite
was stalking Rose. This is like a super weird coincidence. Just
a super bizarre
coincidence. Okay. Oh, what am I doing here? What are we looking
for here? This luring clip is from today. It is.
Was there anything else? Do we finish these logs? Let's see what
else here.
The spoiled drags. Oh, I don't even think we talked about Pixie's
latest like filings or anything either. The latest filings are
really weird. My read on the latest filings is Pixie's lawyers
are like kind of just totally morons. I think she was like almost
entirely in the right. She was basically entirely in the right.
Um, basically what happened was Destiny
was being subpoenaed to get deposed or whatever. Like they wanted
to depose Destiny. It was going to be on November 6th.
Pixie is doing school in a different state. State state pretty
far away, right? She's obviously crowdfunding to pay for her
lawsuit. So
I like obviously she doesn't have a ton of cash. She's in a different
state. Destiny
then subpoenaed her or or gave her notice like noticed her for
a deposition I think is the terminology on November 4th, a date
she explicitly said and her lawyers explicitly said she'd be
at school and she was like, "Oh, I'm coming back for Thanksgiving
or something." So, yeah, I'm coming back for Thanksgiving and
I could be there for these dates or I can do remote like whatever
works best, right? And they're like, "Oh, well, we're we're actually
serving you specifically for November 4th when you say you're
going to be at school and go [__] yourself."
And all Pixie's lawyers had to do, I think, was file like a protective
order to say like, "Hey, that shouldn't be valid. We've already
said that she's at school. She doesn't want to fly back for this.
It seems pretty unreasonable, right? When she could come back
like later or she could do it remotely." But they didn't file
that. So now I don't even know. I think they're they're probably
going to be I would assume they get sanctioned by the court.
We'll see what the court decides.
They'll have to settle for remote. I don't know if they'll have
to settle for remote because Pixie's lawyers didn't actually
say to the court like, "Hey, don't do this. Like don't don't
let this happen." We'll see. I'm I'm guessing they'll end up
all getting deposed on the same weekend for like Thanksgiving
or some [__] But apparently there's another big story
coming up. Their judge is treating their motion as if they filed
it beforehand, which is doing them a kindness. Wait, I don't
even know what. Oh. Oh, is that from today? Did stuff get posted
today? Hold on. Let me go. Let me go take a look. Maybe we have
to read some court docs real quick.
Maybe maybe, maybe, maybe.
Complaint against all defendants.
Wait, what? Oh, no. Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry. I'm reading.
I forgot this switched over. So, it's not it's not set up the
way I expected. Just read the first document. Replying support
motion. Oh boy, there's a bunch of stuff from the past two days.
I think I've I've given like a succinct
a succinct explanation for like what what happened with the original
stuff. Basically, Pixie said they were trying to figure out when
they do depositions. Pixie said, "I can't be here for like this
entire month because unless you want me to do remote because
I'm at school, right, in a different state, but I'm flying back
for like Thanksgiving. So, if you want me to do in person, Thanksgiving
would be really effective, like really good." And then they explicitly
deposed her for not Thanksgiving weekend
knowing that it would be difficult for her to go there. And then
I think they might have even lied. I think they even lied about
what was going on.
So Brettler I I think the idea of their motion was like oh well
Bretler's going to have to fly back and forth from Miami to or
sorry LA to Miami. That's really expensive. And apparently the
weekend where they had Destiny deposed that he didn't show up
for because they Pixie didn't show up for hers on that weekend.
And Brenler was already in Miami, so they were just lying about
it being an undue financial burden for him to be there. Oh, documentary
167.
Hold on.
Uh, give this order expediting response to 163. Motion for protective
order. Here, I'll just move it over.
Court finds good cause to expedite a response from plaintiff.
The response should address why a timely motion for protective
order was not filed when the knowledge of a dispute materialized.
Why sanctions should not be entered under rule 37.
Uh or alternatively by good cause exists. Nunk pro tunk to excuse
plain. Hello
dude. What the just happened? Are we good? I think everything
is dying. Is the mic good?
My headphones are
Can you guys hear stuff just fine? Okay, hold on.
Something just went weird with my headphones. Very bizarre. They're
back.
So, Nunkrunk,
Nunk Pro Tuck,
Nunk Pro to excuse plaintiffs, not attendance at her deposition.
So, why good cause exists? So, they gave her the opportunity
to say why good cause exists. Maybe if good cause exists. I don't
know if I'm actually at school and they knew that is good cause.
I I actually don't know.
We'll see. Right. Cuz it's Sorry. It's
It's good cause for her not to be there, but is it good cause
for them not to file the paperwork required? I don't know if
that's true. I don't think that's true,
but we'll see. Okay, it's not to file. It's or alternatively.
It is or alternatively, right, versus those
But I don't know if I don't know if that's enough because basically
the court should be given notice of this, right? The court should
be updated on this. the court should be kept apprised and the
court wasn't kept apprised. Yeah. Okay. Damn. I didn't, by the
way, I didn't prepare this segment at all. I usually prepare,
but I I wasn't I didn't think we're going to get into this, but
apparently there's a lot of goofy going on, so
you know, we're just we're just rolling with it
best we can. Okay, I think we're done with this. Apparently,
there's another thing like that Rose was being impersonated.
Should we read this? Should we Should we read this transcript,
guys? I'm not I'm not running from the transcript anymore. Should
we read the transcript of apparently Rose?
Is there is there like a Rose deposition that's here in one of
these things? It's got to be like this one filed today. No, no,
no. It's got to be here. Reply and support of motion. Read defendants's
motion to dismiss for lack of jurisdiction.
Oh, sir. Reply. Reply in support of motion. Hold on. Hold on.
>> So, not audite just tipped $5. Why did you stop talking
about me? I said you can hate watch me just don't me while sitting
fat obese on your couch.
>> She did say that. That is true. Let me add the uh
the 4 hours 5 4 hours 6 and we've got 60 there. So we'll put
20 on the next hour. Okay, I'm doing math. Quick math. What do
we got here? This one response and support of motion. Oh, this
is the only thing here. I know what you're talking about from
this. Okay, I know what you're talking about. resetting meters
and then we're going with this. Okay. What is this? Kathy, what
did you just link me? Kathy.
Okay, Cath, stop. Stop. Stop.
this is in support of the motion to dismiss. I think this is
basically just saying that Rose,
the thing referenced here is that Rose
says she was being uh impersonated and it they confirmed the
date of the message, right? So, Mr. Pñena now confirms that Banell's
transmission of the video preceded the effective date of Cardi.
Where's my mouse? Why is this not going? Oh, is that it? Okay,
hold on. Give me a second. Mr. Pñena now confirms that Benell's
transmission of the video preceded the effective date of Cardi.
Mr. Pena's amended declaration eliminates any ambiguity. He now
concedes that Benell's transmission of the video to Rose occurred
on April 9th, 2022. Mr. Pñena's new conclusion is consistent
with the substantial evidence in the record, including all these
other things, including from the non-party deponent whose ex-boyfriend
impersonated her in Discord correspondence he was having with
Banell while pretending to be Rose, as well as plaintiff's own
acknowledgement that she could not conclusively determine that
Banell's transmission of the video of Rose occurred after October
1st, 2022. Okay. So, this is they're saying that Rose is somebody
who is being deposed and that she said her boyfriend was impersonating
her. Yeah. Okay. Now, how does this help
Destiny in some way? I'm trying to think of like how this helps.
So, legally, I don't really think that has anything to do with
whether or not it was a minor or not that he sent the video to,
right? morally or on the internet or even legally in terms of
child.
I'm not sure anything matters if he was still getting videos
of that person, right?
Like were the pictures he posted of the girl who was getting
trafficked? Cuz if they were, then he was looking at that was
shot with a minor. Pixie's filing refers to it as probably ABMC's
depos uh disposition. Wait, deposition. I thought I read disposition.
I was going to correct you and say deposition, but now it says
deposition. Desposition. Desposito.
Okay, I see the issue. My brain's not working so well. I don't
know the laws on that. I If I see on a site, am I still liable?
No, you're not. You're probably not liable. Um, but I believe
it is what is it? An affirmative defense. So, if you are caught
with, you need to prove that you essentially like either called
the cops immediately or did whatever, right? You need to you
can like defend having it, obtaining it. If it's just on a website,
you close it. I don't know if you have to ever go into that,
but if you're saving it or something, I think that's different.
If if you're like retaining access to it in some way.
Yeah, we pointed this out already, J said he called this person
multiple times, which just bizarre.
Uh, I saw what I assume was Hold on. I saw somebody here was
asking a different
Hold on. Where' this guy go? The data is important part re whether
the court can hear the case. Yes, but I think we always I think
RBNA
the thought was from most people who had followed this was that
it was going to be knocked into this realm of like that that
leg of her subject matter jurisdiction was always going to get
knocked out like no matter what cuz it just seemed very obvious
to everybody that was April, right? Just obviously should have
been April in case you want to hear the cope. This is Zip Zip
and some gay lawyer talking about it. Oh, maybe. Let's see. What
is this? >> I feel really bad for Rose considering like
she was never actually a part of this. Um >> the remember
>> this is
>> um
I mean you could say that
but how would they have found out if she was a part of this or
not?
From for all intents and purposes from everybody's perspective
except
for Roses it seemed like she was a part of this, right? She was
a part of this.
Like how how can people get mad about not having facts on the
record? DJ just get mad about statements being in in documents
that aren't on the record and now they're like, "Oh, actually
uh well well actually it's really up that you guys got Rose to
put a statement on the record." I mean, everybody thought that
that was the person. I still, by the way, I still think no matter
what
Yes, Ozel. Yes. I like no matter what happens in this case, I
guess whatever whatever goes on with Rose, it doesn't really
excuse any of Destiny's conduct cuz he he thought he was interacting
with Rose, right? He drove home so many times. I thought she
was I thought she was I thought she was I thought she was 19.
I thought I thought I thought she was. He never said I I thought
she was trafficked. That wasn't his defense. Or sorry, uh it
wasn't that he thought she was being impersonated. He did, I
think, float the oh, she might be traffic thing a little bit
earlier, as in the guy shooting the was probably her boyfriend
who was trafficking her by selling the videos. Not that she was
impersonating, she was being impersonated in the >> It's
called Willie Mac put like just put her ducks on YouTube.
Yeah, >> it's bad enough that people were dancing around
in Ky farms.
>> Where's the is there significant criticism here for
Destiny being the the required? But for Destiny's leaking
of unique PII of Rose, she never would have been found. Is there
is there going to be an element of that? >> Meanwhile,
people Yeah.
It's also like it's it's a thing where like it's still bad that
she wasn't like if she was a person that was texting with Destiny
and this happened. Like obviously it's still bad, but it's just
like is another layer of like gez like this girl's like out there
just living her life and then one day just like everything blows
up and she literally has no understanding what happened and then
she finds out that people thought she was with Destiny. Like
that had to be just >> does this guy think that she wasn't
participating in selling this stuff? like like she was
there there's a world where like a boyfriend is you know abusively
some Andrew Tate like figure is getting her as a minor to take
these photos and stuff right but like she was very aware that
the photos were being taken she was very aware that all of the
photos were being taken that the videos were being
well actually I've never seen a video but I assume I assume if
Destiny had those videos and he's never said oh that's obviously
not her then he must have been operating on the assumption that
it was her right or he would have said that's obviously not her.
Like it helps him out very significantly. >> It's a a brutal,
you know, coming to Jesus moment that people would believe that
about her, but you know, I mean, I hope things get better for
her.
>> This guy didn't say anything that bad. He's I think
he's he's just uninformed or not thinking it through, but he
didn't say anything that bad. He didn't say like, "Oh, this makes
In fact, I think he said, "Oh, this doesn't really help Destiny
in any way." But like, oh, I feel bad for this person. That's
fine. And I mean
like dude it really just goes to show that this has always been
lawsuit is substack which is how this started. Um like
you as we now know from and Destiny said way before we now know
this from the hearing that came out. I said it when at the hearing
came out >> wait what? Destiny and Pixie were working together
before this lawsuit and she got like mind by Lauren de Laguna
or whoever the >> wait why I could have sworn the last
thing Destiny said to Pixie was uh this is like blackmail I feel
like extorted uh go hire a lawyer. Is that not the last thing
Destiny said? He like blocked her. He said go hire a lawyer and
blocked her. Did he not multiple times say like I thought he
also said I there's no problem if you do want to hire a lawyer.
Him and Dan both said that when
I am I She blocked him. Okay. Okay.
I could have sworn that he then blocked her. Wasn't it Nick?
Cuz I could have
was Ardite not the one who said like you need to reach back out
to her. Was that in the context of like reaching around a block?
Cuz I could have sworn he unblocked at some point. I I could
have sworn there was a thing where Arerite was trying to say,
do I am I misremembering these these Discord screenshots of Ardite
saying, "What are the positives of keeping her blocked?" Oh god,
do we have to go back? Do I have to go like go back and get all
of the evidence from this from from like years
years ago? Like uh almost a year ago. Yeah, the meme is the pros
and cons list, but I thought that was to reach back out. Maybe
I'm maybe I'm just like uh not remembering correctly. It's possible.
Maybe write it down. Uh why
I don't I don't particularly like going through this this stuff
right now to be honest with you. It's like it's fun in that I
have like background knowledge, but it's it's like I try to just
do other stuff. I'm uh I'm trying to live my most frolicky life,
okay? I'm trying to frolic to and fro knowing that Destiny is
getting wrecked every day. I try to frolic to and fro, okay?
I try to live my I try to live a in that one way. Okay. in in
terms of my attitude, my freedom, my freedom to go and do whatever
I want. I tried to frolic in a pixie like fashion. Okay. I
got it into her head that she needed to sue Destiny. Like they
were already working on a case to, you know, file with the FBI
like so they can investigate, find out who Solo is and how the
this person had access and to leak everything. And also because
they >> What prevented Dexity from following through with
that? Zip. Zip. What prevented him from following through with
finding the trafficker that that baited him that honeypotted
him and then released all of his videos? What prevented him?
Was it just spite for
Was that the only thing that is still the person who primarily
violated Destiny as well? Why didn't Destiny go after that person?
Can someone
Dude, every criticism Destiny makes of like uh or or these people
make of Pixie on that front just applies perfectly to Destiny.
He was too busy being sued. It was Pixie's fault. That's like
that's unironically what these people all think. It's very weird.
Very sad. >> The Cardi statue, right? Destiny has a case
against Solo who leaked this stuff on Kiwi Farms because that
would be within the Cardi statue because it's after October 1st,
2022. And a massive case because it's like however many videos
that were submitted and it would in fact be there could be multiple
plaintiffs because it wasn't just Destiny's who was leaked. It
was Pixies and whatever else is in there, right?
>> it would be a pretty slam dunk case if they were to
find who Solo is to get this guy for however much get him. >> Well
and let's not forget >> it's all now because D has to sp
waste money on this case. >> Sure. But also let's not forget
a big part of this. Remember let's not forget everybody that
was like oh my god Destiny's got all this child on his computer.
Oh my gosh there's this is going to be this is >> Wait,
hold on. Where where is this fixed? Where is this remedied CFKA?
cuz I'm pretty sure he said explicitly he accepted nudes from
her and that was the the basis for his trust in her was, "Oh,
she wouldn't send me all these nude videos if
if she wasn't trustworthy." I don't know, man. >> Destiny
knew the whole time, blah, blah, blah. Um, so far it's not it
it seems like Destiny did not know this person was underage.
There's a lot of reasons why he would not think that. >> Nobody
thinks that Destiny I mean there's a lot of red flags there,
but but guess what? Those red flags are equally likely to be
that she's underage or that she has her identity stolen,
Not stolen or that she's being, you know, impersonated in some
way. That she won't show you ID. That she can't show like offici
anything like in the moment showing who she is,
right? Oh, wait. Also,
hold on. I'm also remembering I thought Destiny got a picture
of her without
like a picture of her in the moment that wasn't with her ID but
was just like a picture showing she was who she was. Didn't he
Isn't that a part of those Twitter DMs? Am I misunderstanding?
He was like, "Oh, I don't get an ID but she's like I can send
you something now."
Wait, isn't that
Wait, what? Wait, wait, Pardon? I What did
What did he get? What did he get? That was he he did the verification
thing. It's almost like somebody is lying about being impersonated
explicitly because
their primary concern is being charged with trafficking, you
know, sending around Oh,
hold on. Somebody sent me a picture. What was this? This from
a little bit earlier. Hold on. This from the what do you call
it? Oh, this at that Renfair. Okay. Yeah. Sorry. Somebody sent
me like a threads link of Aerodite at the Renfair thing doing
the whole Renfair experience bit. So if you notice this this
person the reason that was in the photos is cuz this person also
got photographed by the same photographer at the same Renfair.
Yeah. Anyway, goofy stuff.
Who is she there with? Uh Nick, I think I would assume. Anyway,
it's just all goofy funny stuff. Okay, hold on a second. Okay.
All right. Where are we going after this? What were we what were
we even thinking about? Oh, we're still watching this guy. >> And
he took all the steps he needed to once he found out about it.
So leaks, >> now that we know it's not >> and he
took all the steps. It seems like Destiny did not know this person
was underage. There's a lot of reasons why he would not think
that. And he took all >> Oh. Oh, the Oh no. This guy was
doing so
This guy was doing incredibly well for a hot second there and
then everything [__] up. >> He needed to once
he found out about it.
>> Wait, where is the evidence of this? So he says, "Oh,
there's nothing no reason Destiny would have known. There's nothing
no way he could have known." And then he took every step he needed
to. >> Porn computer. Oh my gosh, there's this is going
to be this is just Destiny knew the whole time. Blah blah blah.
Um, so far it's not it it seems like >> he knew since November,
>> he did not know this person was underage. There's a
lot of reasons why he would not think that and he took all the
steps he needed to once he found out about it.
leaks. However, now that we know it's not there was no actual
rose, this was a person who was in fact pretend like we knew
it either way, but this is a person who was >> trying to
there was an actual rose. Wait, what? There there is an actual
>> to pretend to not be an underage person. Like, duh.
>> No, no, no. You're missing it. You're missing.
Uh uh um.
So because there's no real Rose, u the fact that he was pretending
and that he was above age means it's okay that she was below
age. Yeah. Cool. Cool. Cool. >> To pretend to not be was
in fact >> Let's listen to that whole thing again. Maybe
I maybe I'm being maybe I'm being unhinged and crazy and and
deranged and maybe I just can't hear what he's what he's articulating
here quite correctly. >> There's a lot of reasons why he
would not. Let me listen to that again. >> And he took
all the steps he needed to once he found out about it. So leaks,
>> now that we know it's not there was no actual Rose,
this was a person who was in fact pretend like we knew it either
way, but this is a person who was trying to pretend to not be
an underage person.
>> This is a person who was trying to pretend to not be
an underage person now that we know that. Wait, wasn't that what
you thought before? What changed? Didn't you think that Rose
was a person who was trying not to be seen as an underage person?
Now it's Now it's an overage person trying not to be seen as
an underage person.
Just any piece of information. Desi's going to start putting
like um Desi's going to put like pictures that are just like
the red box. Okay. He's going to put a big red box on Imager
Link. He's going to file it as emotion and they're going to go,
"OH MY GOD, DESTINY'S INNOCENT." A big red box. A picture of
a big red box. Destiny is innocent, guys. That means he's innocent
on all charges.
Like, duh. >> No, no, no. You're missing it. You're missing
it. Solo Tiny Leaks knew that Rose was under >> Is the
catfisher underage? I'm confused. Is the catfisher underage?
No, but he was catfishing with pictures of somebody underage,
including the videos of people
The the There was a Willie and Only Fans account that was selling
nudes of somebody who was underage. That's that's the issue you
got here. >> Underage when those videos were made. Knew
she was underage in those. Is that confirmed?
Yes, that was confirmed that there was a Twitter account of somebody
who was
uh selling videos underage or whatever. Yes. Now, it's not confirmed
that that Twitter account's even the person, but there is like
some close collaboration between that person
and the so-called
trafficker, right? Yes. Karate Moses. But then uh purportedly
that same trafficker told Destiny the videos were of of her being
underage and then he retained them, right? I believe is the the
criticism that's being levied to Destiny is you were told that
she was underage and you retained all of those videos of her.
That is that's like the
>> videos and then sent them. >> But that that same
criticism holds no matter what happens. Like that was the criticism
back then. It's the criticism now. If you wanted to say, oh,
like I wasn't sent those videos, but he I don't know. Willie
Mack asked him multiple times to to say, "Hey, I uh are you sure
that these sure that you keep these videos? These videos seem
to be of somebody underage. The dates seem to imply she's underage.
Maybe the videos are of somebody else and he just never noticed."
Amy >> to Destiny. So, he knowingly transmitted child assault
material to Destiny. A
child's or child's abuse material. But also, if you believe that
Destiny still got then he retains
then the thing he this guy was saying about the hard drive full
of that is just he had
pretty objectively. He had
>> uh So, not only are all the things you just said true,
but he he did actually do all the >> Oh, did I say OF?
My bad. If I'm perpetuating the OF lie, then yeah. No, she didn't
have OF. She didn't have an age verified platform. She just said
Twitter. Left out the part where he contacted his lawyers about
it. I promise you, Jastaster Tai, I will bet you $500 right now
that he didn't contact his lawyers about it and his lawyers told
him retain that stuff. Cuz that's the thing is he said he retained
it, right? He was sending screenshots to Willie Mack of metadata
of these files. Every single lawyer who has looked at this said,
"Nope, that's insane. That's totally insane. There's no way his
lawyers would say that." So if he told his lawyers, his lawyers
might even be like actually forced to report that
and he retained those videos after the fact. Or so there's one
other explanation. Maybe he went to the cops and he just didn't
tell people about it because he secretly wanted to be looked
at as a child collector.
I mean, I don't know. Guy seems to have a like a total kink for
being humiliated on the internet. I'm not going to rule that
out entirely, but I'd need to see some evidence. So, you don't
believe in expoliation of evidence. Jester Tai, we've already
had you on stream. You are like ADIQ. You speak very slowly.
You cannot comprehend hypotheticals. Okay. God did not grant
you the light to be here. You should just go away
or stay and just continue to be told why you're totally wrong
every single time.
There's no such thing as like you you cannot provide child as
evidence in a
You cannot do child Okay, think of it as like radioactive. It's
the graphite on the top of Chernobyl's reactor number four. Okay,
it's radioactive. You can't present that. It is illegal to possess
it. It is illegal for the court to possess it. Correct.
It's completely illegal for the court to possess it. No, judges
can't hold it. Nobody can hold on to that. It's like cops. Cops
are the people who can hold on to that's it. You can't retain
it. You can't submit it as evidence.
So, you could say, "Oh, well, that's spool." Yep. He might even
be penalized.
almost almost certainly unfairly for spoliation.
But the fact that he had child porn as a part of this case that
him over sure down the line we'll find out what happened maybe.
Who knows?
How do you prove someone has then
uh I just said wait hold on Jertie
who did I say were the people who can handle real quick real
quick. Real quick
Jertie you tell me. Okay. Do you believe that in court? Do you
believe in court that the
jurors on a trial view the child? He also had it say before Pixie
filed her lawsuit, so it doesn't matter. Oh, true. Right. Right.
Ethan Klein. That's a great point that he was informed in November
and then there's two full months before Pixie files her lawsuit.
Actually, I don't even know. I just assume they don't view child
as people in uh on juries, right?
That sounds crazy. I said that and I'm like, "Oh, I don't think
so." the police but not the court. It obviously wouldn't be public
information. I don't know why you're being this pedantic. Yeah,
I don't think judges are allowed to view it either. Is is my
understanding from Sean
uh one of the lawyers who looks at stuff like this. I don't think
judges are even supposed to be are allowed to view it. There
is no such thing as child being presented as evidence. You have
no reason to file you cannot. It is illegal to file child
evidence in a civil case. You could probably use a criminal case
or some criminal reference to it. But I don't think the cops
were involved here.
You do not You do not just save this so that you can use it just
in case. Just in case you have to give it to the court, right?
You don't do that. You do not do
People are trying to act like Destiny did because he knew she
was that age and he knew he was transmitting it. So yeah, he
like if they ever caught this guy, he could 100%
uh potentially face uh charges or, you know, related charges.
>> Yep. Uh, let me read a couple chats. Uh,
>> those would be like child trafficking
you ask. So, is the story that Solo was sexing him the whole
time then when they >> and Destiny? Well, the funny thing
is is I do believe there is this story and maybe this isn't true,
but seems to possibly be the case that Destiny might have been
sharing some of this stuff with like a group chat.
And let me tell you, if that group chat exists and the cops are
looking into this, holy. Cuz if he was sending pictures from
these videos to a group chat,
oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy.
Cuz that would be him
after being told in November that this person was underage.
That would if he if he sent them. Okay.
I personally
I believe it, but listen, it's not it's not foolproof. I think
it's very interesting that he had the picture from VC media player
to send to Willie immediately. Okay. I think that's very interesting.
You remember where he sent Willy Mack the the VC snapshot from
the date believe it was a
August of some month or some year. Whatever year she be 17 in.
Okay.
2021 maybe. Is that when it was 2021? Yeah. August of 2021 was
when she was sending that stuff I think.
And he sent that screenshot to Willy Mack and I'm like, "Oh,
I bet you that's one of the screenshots he took for that group
chat or something.
We'll see.
We'll see. It's not on his computer, guys. It's not on his computer."
Years later, he decided to break character, but he never thought
to blackmail him beforehand. Um,
we don't know exactly cuz I they only deposed Rose as far as
I know. And obviously we don't have access to whatever she said
in their deposition, but so far what we know is that
the let's call her Rose, okay, for lack of a better name cuz
I'm not using her real actual doc's name. Okay. Rose said in
their deposition
that her ex-boyfriend was impersonating her. >> He did
try to blackmail Destiny. Uh, he kind of he kind of tried to
blackmail him. Yeah, he did try to hop on the stream. troop in
correspondence
that with Destiny. So
that's what we know. Okay. So we know that Solo did try to blackmail
Destiny with that couple after the plan appears to be that the
whole time was
like probably just a blackmail and that it was just waiting for
the right moment to do it and it whenever he did it, that's when
it was. Who the [__] knows whatever else? You'd have
to ask solo, but Jesus. Best there is 44 asked. My only thing
is, didn't Destiny say he called Rose before? Um,
hold on. Hold on. We need the
Oh god. Wait, what? Wait, he did. Oh, but Oh no. Oh god. He did.
He really did say that, didn't he? He really
I don't remember if he said that. Possibly. In either case,
it's still like catfishers have called people before, you know,
like use a voice changer or he GOT AN ACT. >> OH,
GUYS, IT'S A VOICE. OH,
hold on. Hold on. >> Called people before, you know, like
did he use a voice changer or he got an actor or
>> whatever, right? Also, what uh somebody else said,
>> he fell for it for hours. Maybe maybe
I Dude, I
everything is like brutal here. It's all very funny. >> Given
her own legal implications, wouldn't her lying on her deposition
be her only choice here if it was her? Else she'd admit to a
lot of crime. No.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's that's also true. Wait,
who asked that? Somebody asked that in DG chat. Maybe. That is
totally true, right? She's she would be admitting to distributing
or to to filming monetarily benefiting from it in some way, right?
Unless she says she wasn't involved. She has to say she wasn't
involved or she's she could be full of then lying if it that
it was her and making up whatever. But we
it f like with public that is known there is a solo like there
was another person that was involved in this.
So they would in what cap in what capacity? I don't I don't know.
Maybe listen maybe that transcript is very fruitful. Maybe that
transcript goes into like details.
But then I think
now the cops have to step in right now. The cops have to look
for this guy. Apparently this girl was apparently this girl was
trafficked. Not just trafficked, but the person who was sex trafficking
her trafficking her honeypotted a couple people got their nudes
and leaked them. This guy's like a prolific criminal. Cops got
to be after him for sure, right? >> Wouldn't make sense.
In theory, it could have been like them two working together
and she's like throwing the solo person under the bus. But
>> I mean, I don't see why we'd have to think that
like this was. By the way, all this is to say nothing at all
about Destiny's consent violations. The obvious clear consent
violations that nobody disputes.
Yeah, that's like like this is saying nothing of that. Solo could
be okay. Doesn't doesn't excuse the consent violations at all
as
seemingly an underage person uh a girl woman now, right? Um
in like even if it was like legally there's some other right
like how much is she responsible if legally she was minor when
this is happening? I have no idea. Maybe Kafka you don't know
more
I'm sorry. I got a work email that I have to respond to. So,
I agree with
>> True. There we go. C agrees. >> Okay. We got anything
else?
>> Got a question for your last
>> Oh, thanks for the followations. Dumb gen here because
Q is gone. Nice. Hawks lead and Glock 19. Sap is the best place
dies. Thanks. He didn't know said drop. So, is Destiny's possession
of them a crime, even though he didn't know? Uh, depends on the
law. Depends on if it's state or federal. I'm not sure. I know
people have said that it's a crime. I believe it is a crime,
but there is an affirmative defense. So long as he immediately
once he learned about it
was able to go to the cops and say, "Hey, this I didn't realize
what this stuff was. Here it is." Right?
That's that's the affirmative defense. Once he had reasonable
suspicion that the person was underage, I think he has to go
to the cops.
Like there is an affirmative defense for being ignorant in some
places. I believe in the in the federal criminal statutes.
Someone correct me if I'm wrong.
Possession is a crime that
um
like is a crime in itself without intent or without knowledge
or whatever. Um but that would require him to be prosecuted for
it. Um, I would imagine maybe Kafka would know differently. But
the reason that the like crimes are like that is so if they can't
conclusively prove that somebody knew and like cuz then anytime
you're possessing you would just say, "Oh, I didn't know." And
then that's it, right? Um, but in this case, there's really good
evidence that he didn't know. And a prosecutor would weigh that
in whether to prosecute. A judge would weigh that in whether
how to sentence. And also there's another person who is guilty
of way higher crimes in this case that being Solo. So that person
they like a pro like a prosecutor prosecutors choose who they're
going to go after. They would choose Solo over Destiny because
they can get that guy in way
>> and get way better like
>> like oh here's what I did today. Boss, I got this guy
Destiny who didn't know that he was receiving from whatever.
Instead, they would go, "Hey, I got this guy Solo who's responsible
for leaking online and
you know all that."
>> Wait, do the cops do that a lot? They're just like,
"Hey, we're only going to go after this other guy and we just
don't care about the other people who had
We only take down in any network of We only take down the guy
with the most child." Actually, that's how it works, guys. That's
how cops work. Let's go.
>> Yeah. I mean it's it's also my understanding is from
uh
what Destiny's said is that he's taken all legal steps he needs
to. He's consulted with his team. >> Um generally whenever
you have
uh child you're not aware of it the the the crime starts when
you become aware of it. >> Um like you have to to know
that it is really for it to be a crime. And there's >> I
believe it's reasonable reasonable
Like obviously nobody is cutting a child's arm off to count the
rings in the bones, right?
Or IDing them or whatever the [__] It's a little
different, but there's a reasonable suspicion. That's it. >> There's
other ways that technically you could, but like generally that's
how it works. And my understanding is in Florida, you then once
you know it is, you have like seven days to essentially report
it, disclose it, and then get rid of it. Um because they want
people because they want >> No, no, no, no. Uh-oh.
As far as we know, he did not.
As as J. Oh, is that Jastaster Tai guy still here? Is he listening
to this?
Where is he listening to this? Seems like even Cfka is sitting
here like, "No, no, no. You can't. You can't just retain that.
You got to get rid of it. You can't just guys, you can't retain
it. Can't do that." >> People to turn that stuff in. Like
it's better for people to turn that stuff in so they can try
to find the victims and help them rather than or the people that
are distributing it rather than people going I have childhorn
and I didn't realize it. Okay, I'm just going to delete it and
then boom now whoever created it, sold it, distributed it. Now
they can't really there's no there's no evidence to go after
them. So they'd rather people turn it in, give those people,
you know, a grace period and say whatever. Um because hey, I
mean it happens, you know, hasn't happened to me but happens
to some people apparently where you just accidentally just end
up with some child Um, okay. I've got we've got seven minutes
until our scheduled debate happens. >> I am updating some
stuff. If you want to keep going with chat, you go ahead. I'm
going to be muted while I get things >> Who does it happen
to? >> Whoever created it, sold it, distributed it. Now,
they can't really there's no there's no evidence to go after
them. So, they'd rather people turn it in, give those people,
you know, a grace period and say whatever. Um because hey I mean
it happens you know has happened to me but happens to some people
apparently where you just accidentally just end up with some
child. Um okay
I've got we've got 7 minutes until our scheduled debate happens.
>> I am updating some stuff if you want to keep going with
>> that's like um
Destin News epid
accidentally ended up with some child.
It happens. >> Chat, you go ahead. I'm going to be muted
while I get things ready. >> Yeah. Um, do we have the um
I'll get that open uh while we're doing that. Um, do we have
in the drive our script? Is that prepare?
>> Okay. All right. That was a funny little >> I
will just be your pay.
>> Riyle donated $3. He didn't have it, but if he did,
he didn't know her age. If he did, he got rid of it in time and
he was
>> Uh, yeah. Exactly. Exactly. Yeah. Wow.
Uh, what are we eat What am I eating? It's uh Mexican food. Taco.
Taco. You see here kind of like traveling around right now. So,
trying new places in different different areas. And
this Mexican place is like maybe the best food I've ever tried
in my entire life. It's like actually crazy. No, it was a soft
taco.
It's a soft taco. It's like the best food I've ever had. It's
like actually crazy how good it is. It's a corn tortilla. Okay.
It's a corn tortilla. Don't call it a soft hako. Okay. It's a
corn tortilla. This is a corn tortilla.
Let it be known. All right.
Listen. We'll We're going to compress this all together. All
right. Oh, wait.
Hold on. Let me look at this again.
Let's check this tweet out. Well, we're just going to do as much
of this stuff. Listen. If you guys want to send in,
uh, I don't mind covering some of it. Not going to cover a lot
of it, but if you send in, I can take a look right now. Hold
on. Why is my trackpad not? It is. Oh, here we go. All right.
Hello at Pixie Love. Can you explain why you fundraised over
$50,000 to sue me, but now you're claiming you can't afford to
come to Florida, where you sued me, by the way, for a court case
and somehow got the money to go to grad school out of state?
Did you just pocket the money to get your fourth degree while
you waste a federal court's time?
I can't quote tweet this guy. Hold on. Hold on. New new tweet
there, guys. New tweet. Did I not get this? Hold on. Not a new
tweet. Not a new tweet. We [__] it up. We [__]
it up. We [__] it up. Totally. Let me delete. God
damn it. Oh,
Let me go back to this stupid [__] tweet. I didn't
get his like name and in there. Hold on. Here we go. There we
go. Boom. There it is. I don't I don't understand how people
don't don't get it. Why? You just pocket the money to get your
fourth degree while you waste a federal court's time. Why?
I guess you just have to either assume these people are doing
it for free or that she had the money from before.
Why would she raise money for a lawsuit? I would assume it's
because she wants to not get bankrupt or doesn't want to spend
her education money on a lawsuit,
right? or she got student loans or there's like a million different
things it could be. It's like super easy to to come up with a
bunch of reasons. The only reason to to say, "Oh, you you raised
money for a lawsuit, but did you did you need to do that?" Is
if they're not spending money in the lawsuit. She spent money
in the lawsuit. I can see it in the motions. I can see all of
the motions that get funded or sorry that get filed rather but
also get funded. Jesse showed up to talk to food shops last night.
Ugh. Dude, are you really Was it because I just said I was eating,
Ryle, that you have to link this? Are you serious?
I I just said I was eating. All right, we'll check this out.
We'll do this short segment.
>> And but you showed up in person. >> Um, we showed
up to Deposer. Yeah. >> And Andrew Brettler was also there.
>> I don't know which my law firm was there. I don't know
which attorney was there, but >> Oh, okay. So, so your
lawyers were like you had at least one lawyer with you, right?
like on the >> I didn't have to go I don't have to be there
for the deposition taking, but my lawyers were there. Yeah. And
a court reporter. Yeah.
>> That's wild. The fact that um she didn't show up to
her own deposition and none of her attorneys showed up to the
deposition.
Um but your lawyer showed up and they wasted their time. Essentially,
they wasted their time and money. And I'm assuming they're also
charging you for the time. >> Yeah. That's why we >> I
just said I was eating. >> That's crazy to me. Okay. I
I think I think for me that's probably one of the worst parts
is the fact that you have to pay your lawyers and your lawyers
show up for agreed upon deposition and they're still charging
you. Um but
>> uh obviously not agreed upon at all.
>> It's not your lawyer's fault. It is like Pixie is trying
to use your lawyer's fees in order to punish you. Um that's the
way that from her perspective at the very least I see it. um
from I I don't think Brett did Bretler hide this that it was
that she was at like law school or whatever like that's what's
happening right because he's at law school that's she literally
said I am not going to be able to be there cuz I'm at law school
in a different state >> so on November 6th what happened
so
>> nothing I didn't go home she skipped her deposition
so we filed a protective order with the court and said we're
not going to mine and the judge approved and then forced them
to file a show cause for why they skipped theirs and didn't notify
the court they were going to move >> Yeah, this is the
show cost for that. >> Okay. There there was no hearing
on the six. No hearing or deposition on the
>> Okay. All right. Cool. Um
All right. I guess what would this come down to? Like if Bretler
basically just lied in his deposition, is there actually some
strategy about not filing a protective order? I don't I don't
know. I'm trying to think of like a way that you I could make
sense of Pisky Pixie's lawyer's decisions. Like what could possibly
make sense here? I have no idea.
Cuz really,
man, let me Is there like some strategy to like, oh, okay,
if Andrew Breler is like just going to lie about what we discussed,
they're going to like depose us and he's just going to lie about
what we discussed when he knows exactly what's going on and he
totally misrepresents what's happening. Like, does that work
out in their favor? I don't know. Could they have even known
that that he would lie? Like
I don't think so. >> Wait, actually, let me just share
my screen so then you know what I'm reading right now. Okay.
Wait, hold on. I didn't catch your answer. Are you traveling
right now?
>> Where are you?
>> I'm in LA.
>> Okay. Um, defendant has not demonstrated good cause.
Rule 26 requires a specific showing of good cause, not conclusory
claims of inconvenience. Defendant offers and has none. He confirmed
availability for November 24. I I'm going to be totally honest,
okay, as I'm reading through this like stupid document. Um
like all the dates just pass me by, okay? Like at some point
I just stop keeping I just I just can't keep track of any of
the dates. I'm sorry. It's just there's just so many stupid dates.
Like no one's going to remember anything anyway. It's just I
don't care. Yeah. Unilaterally notice plaintiff for November
3rd knowing she was unavailable. His claim >> This is basically
how all this works. Okay. Are you um
>> What city did you say you live in again? Do you say
>> uh I live in Cali?
>> Okay. Um
it's the 12th.
On the 15th, you want to go out to eat. >> Whoops. My bad.
>> Oh no. >> What? What?
Hold on. >> On the It's the 12th.
>> On the 15th, you want to go out to eat?
>> On the 15th? Imagine I'm asking you. On the 15th, you
want to go out to eat? Uh
>> Oh no. >> Are are are you are are you where? >> Okay.
Oh no. Oh no. Oh no.
No. No.
No way. Oh the 15th. Yes. Yeah. >> Where are you? On the
15th. >> Okay. All right. I'm not available to eat until
like
the 30th. So should I go on the 30th or the 29th?
So
Destiny's giving a hypothetical for how they're scheduling the
deposition and Food Chops is trying to figure out how to deal
with the anxiety she feels about being asked to go for dinner
with Destiny, which has not happened. I'm just waiting. When
will the realization kick in? When will it kick in? Oh, MVTT.
It's for a hypothetical. Yes. Yes. Yes.
as a former mod of this stream is probably the least member of
that community. There must be like a king over there or something.
What? You're You're not Wait, sorry. Can you repeat
>> I'm not available to eat until the 29th or the 30th.
So, which day should I go? >> Any day would be fine. Just
whatever is up to your choosing. I guess it's not a
>> Okay, I'll do the 30th then.
>> Okay. Are you >> But you're going
still. Wait,
she still hasn't figured it out. She still hasn't figured it
out. Oh no.
Why are you Don't bring anyone with you. Make sure you're alone.
Okay. Just what? What is No.
>> Oh no.
Oh no. Dude.
>> Oh my god. >> She actually has no This is about
to be the best moment of food shops life. I feel like I feel
like Destiny has to actually go out for dinner with her now.
And he's in LA as they're speaking, right? Maybe he'll be back
in LA soon. I feel like
you actually just broke this human being. She actually thought
about asking to move in with him. Uh, well, we watched a little
bit of that video. Do you think Oh, do you think Destiny gets
embarrassed that this is the caliber of people left to defend
him?
Uh, I don't know if Destiny is capable of embarrassment.
He's capable of shame. I don't know if he's capable of embarrassment.
No, I mean like I'm not going to be there on the I'm not going
to be on the 15th, but I just agreed to go on the 30th, but you're
going alone on the 15th.
>> That's this is the game that their lawyers played is
we were trying to set up a deposition and they said, "Okay, well,
there's like the third." >> Okay. Okay. You're trying to
demonstrate. Okay. You're trying to demonstrate the the point
here, right?
>> And so we agreed, yeah, the third is fine for us. How
about for you guys? And they're like, how about next month? And
we're like,
>> dude, the we said the six Okay. And they're like, well,
hold on. the the point here
>> I've never
I've not seen someone get like
I this like arrested development or something but it's happening
in real time right >> yes and then and so we agreed yeah
the third is fine for us how about for you guys and they're like
how about next
>> and we're like or the we said the six okay they're like
>> I I think it's so sad dude MVTT if you ever want to
come back here okay I I thought you were like
I that you were really [__] you are like the only
person this MVTT guy is like the only person who could tell that
it was a hypothetical
like yeah amnesty I can't watch you exist in that community around
people who thought this was real who thought this was like their
moment their community is finally being recognized the leader
of this community gets to go and meet Destiny in person oh my
god I with you make sure yeah total amnesty okay you can come
back you can come back it's okay >> you're alone okay just
What? What is >> No, I mean like I'm not going to be there
on the I'm not going to be on the 15th, but I just agreed to
go on the 30th, but you're going alone on the
>> That's This is the game that their lawyers played is
we were trying to set up a deposition, and they said, "Okay,
well, does like the third or >> Okay. You're trying to
demonstrate." Okay. You're trying to demonstrate the the point
here, right? >> Yes. And then and so we agreed, yeah, the
third is fine for us. How about for you guys? And they're like,
"How about next month?"
>> Sure, bro.
Okay, I'm going to keep reading. Okay. his claim of undue burden
or expense.
I'm just gonna just gonna keep reading.
Moreover, out of council's uh out of states out of state council's
desire to have the party's deposition scheduled consecutively
does not constitute good
>> particularly when it conflicts with the schedules of
plaintiff and her counsel. Defendant has not cited any authority
and there is none giving outofstate council's convenience priority
uh over local parties and council. Courts have routinely rejected
that argument in blah blah blah blah blah the court denied can't
imagine this would be allowed court president when it comes to
like the plaintiff having to attend classes or having any kind
of like scheduling error. I can't imagine scheduling errors are
fine. No, that's okay. Like you were supposed to work with each
other to figure out when to schedule these depositions. Like
that's fine. The ridiculous thing is she said she's not available
for the entire month and it would be burdensome for her to travel
to Florida, but she sued me in the state of Florida. So the fact
that she [__] moved is beyond [__] [__]
She would use a like it can't be burdensome to attend a deposition
in the state that Well, I think it's it could be burdensome to
attend it in person. It's possible when she filed the lawsuit,
she might not have known what law school she was going to, right?
It's entirely possible she wasn't accepted to a law school yet,
right?
That that by definition, that can't be like a bad faith, you
know, thing to do. You sue in the state where the crime happened
and then you have to you're going to law school. You keep living
your life. Should she just like put her life on pause, I guess?
And she has the no frolic. Pixie, frolic, don't put your life
on pause. >> That you filed a suit on. That's so
Did uh did Pixie's team or did Pixie's council notice you that
they weren't going to hold it on November 3rd anymore before
November 3rd? >> They didn't file any
>> Yeah, we see. Exactly. Yeah, they totally let us know
they weren't going to be there, but but obviously they forgot
to file with the court. They didn't file with the court. >> Oh,
okay. So, you're saying that they let you guys know. However,
she didn't do anything with the court. Like, you're supposed
to file it officially with the court. >> They didn't file
anything with the court. We said we let the court settle it out.
We noticed them for the depo on the third and we said they can
take it up with the court if they don't like it and they didn't
do with the court.
>> Okay. Jesus. Oh my god. Okay.
Um,
defendant is not entitled to sanctions.
Defendant seek sanctions claiming plaintiff failed to coordinate
depositions or appear but the record shows the opposite. Plaintiff
repeatedly proposed reasonable dates. Defendant refused to cooperate
and sent an invalid notice. Courts deny sanctions in these circumstances
as a matter of course. Um do you know why they keep on repeating
reasonable
like any reason? They just say random things. If you say reasonable
enough they think it it becomes reasonable. just the
>> Okay, I I'm actually kind of surprised.
Um I'm actually kind of surprised. >> Uh what does Destiny
get gain out of keeping this creature around? Somebody who will
defend them no matter how they look. No matter how how they like
argue, they'll defend no matter what. Right? There'll always
be a place where literally Food Chops doesn't have to say anything
intelligent at all. Everybody around her will like the only thing
the only things she ever says that are remotely intelligent are
just things she takes from Chad, right? It's just somebody who's
going to take his side no matter what. I think eventually she's
going to try to break away, but it won't >> That uh you
know such like casual court papers and like for example >> dude
is Pete Hexith I feel like Pete Hexith is like a thousand times
more competent than food shops. So I feel like that's unfair
to Pete Hexith
unfortunately even though I think Pete Hexith is obviously scum.
Trying to think, is there somebody even more embarrassing they
put in the cabinet
I don't know. Maybe not. Maybe that's the best hypothetical we
could do. >> Um, earlier in the paper, uh, they said the
word shenanigan. Is that even like the There's no way this is
like legal language or some
This is This is uh the level they've gotten to. Okay. Yep. Yep.
Guys, dismiss. Motion to dismiss.
Lawyers for the other side said the word, they use the word shenanigans.
Okay,
not in any legal dictionary.
Imagine I'm going to pull up the Super Troopers clip, but I'm
not going to do it right now. >> Right. Like, >> keep
going. >> I feel like I feel like I should be reading jargon,
not like everyday language. No, >> I mean reasonable can
be everyday language, but I mean all these filings are just like
really stupid. So that's it's just all of it is just dumb. >> Okay,
cool. Moreover, plaintiff's decision not to move for a protective
order was made in good faith. Reliance uh reliance on president.
Listen, Chad, okay, I'm still shook. Um in blah blah blah, the
court declined to impose sanctions. I am in I am in ruins
pieces. The court declined to impose sanctions. >> Why?
What? What is she even? She just read a sentence and said something
that makes no sense. What? What here are you confused about?
>> Were the opponent neither appear nor sought a protective
order for a deposition unilaterally scheduled by opposing council.
The court reasoned that the dispute could have easily could have
been >> No, no, no. I this is like critical to understand
the people who watch food shops that she just read something.
She had a reaction. the fact the the piece of reality she just
examined has nothing to do with the commentary that came out
of her mouth after examining that piece of reality. Right? That's
what I'm telling you. Like that is and the kind of people who
can't connect those things, who don't listen, who just want somebody
who's going to like act like the other people are wrong. That's
all they want, right? They don't want any nothing. There's nothing
going on. Yeah, I know. I know she's shook cuz she doesn't get
to go for lunch with Destiny. I get it. >> Or declined
to impose.
I am in I am in ruins
pieces. The court declined to impose sanctions where the opponent
neither appear nor sought a protective order for a deposition
unilaterally scheduled by opposing count could have easily could
have been easily resolved through cooperation and that the noticing
party had no one but himself to blame for proceeding despite
clear indications the deposition would not occur. Clear indications
like not filing with the Okay. Like,
so she asked, "Hey, did you send something?" She knows. She knows.
She, trust me, she could identify that, right? That obviously
Pixie's lawyers let Destiny's lawyers know. She's not going to
be there for that date. She's not in the state. She's literally
not in the state. Also, I think what's funny is we have a law
channel in discord.gg/jstk
if you guys want to join the Discord. It's the rape defense squad
channel. Okay? Everybody talks about court cases there. Not just
this court case anymore. We talk about a lot of different court
cases. Okay? Go join that channel.
Yeah. Put indications like them saying so. Exactly.
But she's like like just not noticing the court. Well, I think
h how how should we put this? So,
we we can take a look. We'll take a look cuz I think Pixie's
lawyer or Pixie's lawyers actually argue this. Well, I think
I looked at this and and her lawyers argue this well as the unfortunate
thing for her lawyers is there's just no reason not to file the
protective order. Like I'm guessing it wasn't that burdensome.
It wouldn't take more than like an hour or two to file to like
write it up and give it to a clerk to file. There's probably
just no reason for them not to do that.
I still think Pixie is like totally in the right. She's college
student who didn't want to come down until Thanksgiving or was
willing to do it remotely. You don't want to take either of those
options. just being like an like a petty as for no reason. Which
Destiny openly like says,
but I I assume the courts aren't going to be like, "Oh yeah,
we're going to support you being a petty [__] to
the person you victimized
cuz Destiny doesn't deny like violating her consent. He just
denies that he did it before a certain date or sorry, after a
certain date." Relying on iguana. Nice. That's a lizard, right?
plaintiff reasonably believed that formal um motion practice
was unnecessary once she had clearly and repeatedly advised defendant
of her unavailability uh unavailability for the unilaterally
notice date. Her written notice satisfy rule 26's good faith
requirement and her non-appearance was substantially justified.
Nice. Wait, the the judge and the court has already reprimanded
her for this, right?
>> No, I don't think so. This is what we're dealing with
right now is if there's going to be a reprimand, right? >> Okay.
Do you do you think that uh reprimanding is going to happen?
>> Hold the line. This happened. >> I mean, I don't
think that they gave a good reason
based on this. I I don't I just It's easy to file something with
the court contesting a notice deposition. I don't know why you
wouldn't do that.
>> You could easily do that.
>> Doesn't really mean it's like okay to do that kind of
uh to do that kind of noticing. Doesn't mean it's like a good
idea. Doesn't mean the court's going to take your side. Although
I feel like the court at this point with Pixie's lawyers, I do
think they will be like, "Yeah, [__] you guys." I
could see them finding finding her or something. We'll we'll
see exactly what happens. Yo, Zipset, thank you so much for the
raid. What the When is the last Oh my god, over 300 viewers.
What the [__] are you
Wait, Cory, thank you so much for the
Buy yourself a Subway sandwich on the 15th. Yeah, alone. >> Just
a martini.
>> buy yourself a Subway sandwich on the >> Thank
you. Making me watch free shops. You don't have to watch me.
You can literally just click off and go watch somebody else.
Okay, I'm pretty sure Peace Go streaming right now. Go chew.
Defendants claim travel costs are unreoverable. He traveled to
Miami for another matter, not the canceled deposition, and courts
routinely deny reimbursement for travel by out of state council
for an inform deposition.
Defendant also accumulated unnecessary costs for a court reporter
despite knowing that plaintiff would not appear and thus this
cost is unreoverable. Defendant also accumulated unnecessary
knowing that plaintiff would this cause so stupid. Whatever the
fees for preparing the motion are likewise unreoverable since
defendant could have easily avoided these cuts by proceeding
with defendants to confirm deposition
on November 6 and taking plaintiff's deposition on November 24
25. This court has specifically denied sanctions where here there
was no confusion that plaintiff was unavailable but nonetheless
defendants scheduled the deposition and incurred unnecessary
costs and fees. Well, the the unnecessary costs and fees is in
regards to uh your lawyer's fees, right? For the deposition where
she didn't show up in,
>> yeah, insure plaintive act. >> So, hold on. Did
I just I didn't just miss it, did I? I don't think so. There's
there's a part in here where I believe they say that Brett was
already like admittedly going to be in Miami. So, him saying
that like the fees for him flying being like unnecessary or burden
were just was just like a lie. is in regards to uh your lawyer's
fees, right? For the deposition where she didn't show up in,
right?
>> Insure plaintiff acted with good faith and substantial
justification.
Defendant manufactured the conflict and should not profit from
his own non-ooperations. >> Yeah. Yeah. They are >> scheduling.
Defendant's unjustified insistence on scheduling the party's
depositions on consecutive days despite the burden on and unavailability
of the plaintiff or plaintiff's council has
The progress of discovery.
The deadline for discovery.
>> Huh? What what
>> has disrupted
>> defendants's unjustified
insistence on scheduling the parties depositions on consecutive
days
despite the burden on and unavailability of the plaintiff or
plaintiff's council has disrupted the progress of discovery.
Listen, it's just bad grammar, okay? just whatever. Basically,
they're just saying, "Well, it's because you're not willing to."
>> Wait, is it
defendants's unjustified insistence on scheduling the party's
depositions on consecutive days despite the burden on and unavailability
of the plaintiff or plaintiff's council has disrupted the progress
of discovery?
>> Wait, what was what was wrong with the grammar there?
scheduling the parties depositions on consecutive days.
this discovery.
>> Huh? What?
What? >> Has disrupted has disrupted the progress whatever
the um it's disrupting the >> Does she know Does she know
what this motion is supposed
to be? >> Yeah. Go ahead. >> Does she I don't think
she understands what she's supposed to be filing for. She She's
trying to explain right now why they weren't able They're trying
to explain right now why they felt like they couldn't attend
this deposition or why they couldn't agree on scheduling. >> The
judges asked them to file. Why did you not file a protective
order? That's the question.
Is Has she given any reason why they couldn't file a protective
order? >> I thought No, no, no. I thought there was also
if they could provide good reason for
for not filing or for her failure to to turn up, right? I thought
there was also that whole thing.
No. Also, I believe there's I believe there's also how like facts
that Breler left out of his filing.
>> They they've made a wrong essay. They didn't they didn't
understand the essay
>> No. Yeah. They just don't understand what's going on.
Imagine you no call. >> It's funny that um it's funny that
Destiny has to show up to read the documents himself on this
other stream. Like this person doesn't understand. probably doesn't
want a paper trail anymore of telling this person what to say.
So, he's got to show up and and interpret for them. >> It's
very interesting.
>> Oh, no. And then you show up the next day. And I'm like,
you're fired, bro. You didn't come in. And you're like, no, no,
no. You don't understand. Like, I had a really good reason not
being at work. And I'm like, that doesn't matter. Why didn't
you call? You have to call. You can't just no call no-show unless
you were like unconscious.
And then you're like, well, no, like I was sick and I had a like
really bad pneumonia. Like, I don't care what the reason was.
you need to tell me why you couldn't give me a call. Right. The
judges the jud the I could go look it up, but I'm pretty sure
this order unless I'm unless I don't remember any of this, but
I'm pretty sure the order the expedited response timeline and
everything was for the court to um be it's for them to explain
to the court why did you not file a protective order? You had
time. You saw that this was noticed. It was on the docket. If
you knew that there was a dispute on the timeline, then you should
have filed a protective order with the court. Why didn't they?
What is a protective order supposed to do again?
>> it would have made it so that they didn't have to apply.
They wouldn't have had to attend the >> shielding them
from the notice of the >> deposition. Like, I'm pretty
sure that's what we um
that's what we did. >> And what's the reason for that
for normally for protective orders?
>> What's the >> Okay. All right. >> But the
problem is that the court saw that there was a deposition scheduled
on the third. Everybody knows it. the dockets are public and
pixies stupid whatever decided that they were above telling the
court whether or not they were going to attend the deposition
because they're just too cool for that and so we showed up ready
to do the deposition cuz that's when we told the court was going
to happen they didn't show up and now the judge is looking at
the docket and the judge is like excuse me um you had a thing
that was scheduled on the third why didn't you show up and now
Joan is going through all of her personal pity party reasons
for why oh well you know my client is now you know going to some
out of state law whatever school for 50,000 a year and she's
too bougie you show up whenever, you know, it's got to be on
her timeline and the judge doesn't give a about that. That's
for us to decide. The the question is why didn't you file with
the court saying that you weren't going to be I think there is
a huge thing for the lawyers like not filing. I just don't think
it hurts Pixie's case. I'm pretty sure like failure by the lawyers
to do things actually don't really affect Pixie's case at all.
It's not like she's going to be she's going to get some like
negative inference. It's not like anything bad's going to happen
to her. It's basically just Destiny's really bitter at her lawyers
right now.
Wait, so Pixie's lawyers told them they couldn't make the date,
but then de's lawyers went through with the whole Salt Goodman
act of trying to stick them with the penalty. Um,
well, D's, so basically they said we can't do this, right? And
I think the way it works is if you notice somebody for a deposition
and it's unreasonable, you're supposed to file with the court
to say, "Hey, I received a notice that my client's required for
a deposition. I think this is unreasonable because I told opposing
council that she's at school right now and she offered this date
remote, this date remote, and then she offered to be able to
do it in at Thanksgiving.
So like November 20th or something, right? Somewhere in there.
So I think we we think that's reasonable. That's what they should
have filed with the court to say, "No, no, no. This thing that
that where they booked the court and they're going to use the
court's time for this. No, no, no. Don't do that. Actually, we
told them we couldn't be here. We want a protective order to
get out of this." They should have done that, right? But for
whatever reason, they just went, "No, she's not going to show
up." And they didn't really pay attention or care. I don't know
if they dropped the ball. I don't know if they think the sanctions
aren't that high. I have no [__] idea why they would
do that, right? But it's like Pixie has every reason not to be
there. She's been flexible in getting around it.
Doesn't Destiny say Pixie is disgusting for wasting the court's
time? Uh, yeah, but he just said I was disgusting for showing
Rose's docks on screen watching a Willy Mac video, which a million
other people did, including him, I believe. Right. Did he not
watch the Willy Mac video? I could have sworn he did. Maybe he
only watched the second part or maybe you skipped that part.
But a lot of people watched that Willy Mac video,
And he is the person who provided the unique PII to do sir. He
is the actual disgusting person in this case.
Yes. Yes. Sweatpants freedom. He is playing games knowing she's
not around, knowing his audience will support it the whole time.
Yep. >> At the deposition, but but I Joan might not be
able to read. I'm not sure. Who
>> Bro, what a wacky case. So, they answered
they answered the wrong they they thought the question was different,
gave a different answer. The answer doesn't even apply. And even
in the answer itself, there are errors and it makes no sense.
>> Yeah. Here, do you want you want to real quick? What
do you mean? Hold on. Scroll up. Do you guys think that Bettler
is doing this pro bono for Destiny?
Or do you think Destiny's like getting these stunts to be done
knowing it doesn't affect the case? It might at best get Pixie's
lawyers hit with a
I think that's at best. And he probably paid another 10 grand
for this to be done. Like that's how spite based he is. That's
how spitefilled he is. He needs to go and pay Breer like a money
to go and do these stunts and then they don't show up and he's
like, "Well, whatever. Oh, I I'll just pay for it.
Doesn't hurt Pixie's case. Doesn't help his case. Gives him like
something to talk about on Twitter, I guess. Maybe
on his demonetized platforms, but >> I don't know do this
or if you're
not. Okay. Um, let's scroll up for a second. Okay. But wait,
don't Hold on. I'm just trying to
>> I'm just I'm reading the cases they said. Hold on. Despite
my appear on this quest of recoverable >> or you can just
open it on your phone or some I don't know. I can't open anything
on my phone. I'm looking at your stream. >> No, you can
open on your phone. Do you not have a PDF reader for your thing?
>> Maybe that's why Pixie is doing this stuff. She wants
him to use as much as much money as possible.
Well, I mean, maybe that could be the strategy at this point.
I have no idea.
But I do think that
both sides have been trying to fill up like I would say the the
docket with motions.
It feels like both sides have been trying to fill up the docket
with motions. I still, like I said, this was just like a layup
for Pixie side. I have no idea why they
why they did this. It's possible Pixie said, "I really don't
want to have to go." Like, I'm I'm trying to think of a hypothetical.
Maybe Pixie says something like, "Oh, I have like a final I have
like an exam coming up. I really don't want to go on that date.
I don't think I can't go. I can't go. I can't go." And they're
like, "Well, we'll just ignore it because if we if we file a
protective order and they deny it, you have to be here." But
now we have like some means of going, "Oh, well, we're the ignorant
party, right?
Pixie's motions were all are all legitimate. This is purely to
be on the annoying side. Maybe
I think CFKA Esquire just followed. So, we'll see. He's got 3
minutes until he can chat. We'll see what he has to say. >> Open
what? I'm just reading the thing. >> You're able. Okay.
Whatever. Okay. All right. I You can't just rely on my Oh my
>> I guess in Discord. >> Okay. All right. All right.
Yeah. Go ahead. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Scroll more.
I What? What is the complaint?
>> Like push page up on your keyboard.
It's not working.
>> Okay. My guess is if you go >> What page DO YOU
WANT ME TO GO TO? What page do you want me to go to?
>> I don't know. Don't worry. If my guess if you look up
any of the cases they absolutely riveting with protective orders,
I would be shocked if any of the cases that she's citing have
to do with skipping notice depositions. But
>> are you done reading?
>> I'm sure. Oh, I think the
I think
the issue with this one, the Iguana LLC versus Lam is this that
it's filed in a different
like a different state court, right? It's not a precedent from
Florida. It's just it's a president from
Maryland MD MDG. I don't know. I don't know. It's like a president
from a different court.
So, I think I think the issue is like this president probably
isn't rock solid to rely on.
I wouldn't be shocked if there's just a history of judges going,
"Oh, you you noticed them for a date. They like explicitly couldn't
be there and then they told you they weren't going to be there
and you didn't like raise anything else with the court,
right? It's the whole month before." That's probably not reasonable,
right? Discovery is about to end. You can't take the whole month
of November off when Discovery ends, like I think the first week
of December, right?
So, you have to make yourself available for some other times
than just this one time. And when do you want that to be? But
then I think they would just allow remote for the person who's
out of state.
That's the thing is probably the the reasonable next step was
saying, "Hey, these people won't accept anything." Well, actually,
it might have just been accepting remote, maybe.
Okay, you need to install a PDF reader. >> PDF reader.
I just don't want to open three different [__] tabs
and all >> while you're talking to me because Discord runs
open and I'm looking at it on Discord.
>> No, no, no. You can open a PDF reader, read the document
on your phone. >> I know. Yes, I'm aware of that, but I
don't want to get one and then go to the website and then download
the PDF and open there when I'm literally just looking at it
on Discord.
>> In short, plaintiff acted with good faith.
Okay.
Um, propose sketching.
Why is this? Wait, it's so stupid now. Now that I know like now
that I know it's like like it's not even understanding the question.
Whatever. Defendants unjustified insistence on scheduling the
party's depositions on consecutive days despite the burden on
and unavailability of the plaintiff's council has disrupted the
pro uh >> Oh, hold on.
I see this in the Discord.
Uh has
Nick Nick
famous as paradise Spartan husband has joined the discord has
come in to argue with.
So is Rose like mega doxed again now? No. Oh, how'd you find
her at the fair? I spent a lot of time getting her profiles taken
down from various places. Ah, well that was very nice of you.
Yeah, Sya.
Sya just didn't want this person like gigadoxed. So I think in
the interim he was like helping this person. I think I think
he might have even talked to this person about getting stuff
taken down.
I just think that's that's very funny.
It's very very funny.
H I think I think we could use this as evidence that the Jtock
Discord is a doxing place. The fact that they never mentioned
this, they let it go on for months without mentioning it and
now they've only shown pictures. I think it's like a doxing place.
Nope.
Nope. Try again.
Good luck. >> Of discovery. Nice. The deadline for discovery
in this map. >> What's the fair? Oh, you should go back
and watch just the little reveal on that, Missy Elliot. Go back
and watch. We've just been like memeing about it in the Discord
for a while. >> There is December 16th. In addition, after
December 16th, is that like when Discovery ends forever?
>> And then what happens?
Um, then we both prepare our motions for a summary judgement,
assuming the judge doesn't rule favorably on our motion to dismiss.
And then I think we do mediation to see if the case could be
mediated.
Um, and then we do um and then absent that, then we get ready
for a
>> Okay. I'll prepare to quit streaming somewhere after
that. Okay. In addition to the plaintiff's recently requested
dates for >> Okay. Destiny. Destiny knows he's supposed
to cut in there and go, "No, no, don't. No, don't quit streaming.
You shouldn't quit streaming after that. You could totally keep
streaming after the court case. No, stop. Stop."
But he didn't do it. He didn't say feel like I'll prepare to
quit streaming somewhere after depositions. Defendant recently
requested dates for the depositions of I
one I [__] know of one plaintiff's expert witness
for another non-party witness deposition on December 8th in Washington
DC. Moreover, defendant has until November 17 to announce a rebuttal
expert and if he does, plaintiff will be seeking to depose that
expert.
Okay. The expert witness.
>> Is this my music? My music seems like kind of loud.
Is this loud? No, it's not >> Should take place after the
lay witness depositions have concluded.
>> Additionally, gentle will the mediation deadline is
December 23rd and the mediation date has not yet been set by
the parties. Finally, plaintiff's council, Miss Peters, is traveling
outside of Florida
from November 21st until the 30th in an effort. [__]
to coordinate the remaining depositions without extending the
December 16th deadline. Plaintiff proposes uh proposes the following.
Number one, November 24 or 25 for plaintiffs deposition in Miami.
Well, I
>> I I I assume that you want I assume that you want Pixie
to show up in person, >> but yeah, >> you also you
also want her attorneys to show up in person with her, right?
>> I don't I don't give a [__] She doesn't
have to have her attorneys with her. She'll definitely want them
though. But yeah, Pixie and her probably her attorney needs to
be there in person. >> Okay. December 3rd for deposition
of nonparty nonparty witness deposition who resides in Texas
requested by defendant. The non-party witness is not represented
by plaintiff's council and defendant has not served her with
>> I just love that Pixie is kind of just so
still so still so still so totally sorry not Pixie food jobs
like totally mind on this so she's like oh you'll deny this one
too cuz like you need her lawyer there right oh sorry 24th 25th
you'll deny that one too right like you need her lawyer her lawyer
needs to be there right no the subpoena it's just about inconveniencing
Pixie
on
is this is this talking about Abby? Wait, December 3rd for
Is this Abby?
>> Maybe. I don't know. >> That's literally the only
person it could be if you knew anything about the
>> Does Abby reside in Texas?
>> Okay. December 8th for nonition
subpoenaed by defendant December 10 or 11 for defendants deposition
in Miami
16 for plaintiffs expert. Okay. All right. So, it's just some
random ass dates. Okay. Conclusion.
Defendants motion is a >> who's in DC? There were they
were talking to somebody in DC. I forget who it was. I thought
that was Abby, but maybe it was um the Illinois nonparty witness.
transparent attempt to shift blame for his own discovery. >> Oh,
Dagon is in Texas. Apparently, the record shows that plaintiff
acted. >> But does the rest of this
December 3 for deposition of non-party witness deposition who
resides in Texas requested by defendant. The nonparty witness
is not represented by plaintiff's council and defendant has not
served her with subpoena. This is just a suggested date. Oh,
this could be deuna too with professionalism,
flexibility, and good faith.
Uh while defendant engaged in gamesmanship, yeah, Steven loser,
unilaterally setting an unavailable deposition date and refusing
to appear for his own solely to accommodate his outofstate council.
The court should deny defendant's motion for protective order,
deny his request for sanctions, and order the parties to schedule
all remaining depositions on dates that are available and convenient
for all parties in their council. Wherefore, for the >> we
covered it. Crisp >> re is that the court denied defendants's
motion for protective order and his >> We covered it when
it came out. Yeah. Weird moment. One's a lot better.
>> Okay. The second one's a lot better. Let me go to it.
Hold on.
>> I think it's it's very very clear that he's drunk while
doing this, which is >> Do Are we recording each other
now? >> Okay, cool. >> Uh I'm going to go to my boss.
>> Okay. Be careful. Say bye. I'll see you
Why? Why are you following me? >> Cuz I'm bored. I gangstalk
in real life. >> You're a [__] freak. You're
>> I mean, ropes.
>> True. Queen, stay safe. Be careful. >> Yeah. So,
why?
>> And then he posted this.
He actually he actually went and posted
Didn't she find him? I mean, he said he was following her. I
think I think they must have bumped into each other and she walked
up to him and started saying something and then she started apparently
walking away and he followed. Is that what's going on here?
I don't know why he said, "Yeah, I'm following you." Maybe he's
just saying, "That's bad."
I think he walked past her job and she chased him down. Oh, maybe.
I have no idea. I didn't see the walk up or the the leadup to
it, even less.
Oh, just to be clear, I had zero idea she was here and she just
runs up to me with her phone and starts recording me out of nowhere.
So, I take a video because why not?
Dude, how do so many people not understand the concept of the
fungeability of money?
I just don't I don't get it.
People People are trying to do the whole uh Keles attack on Pixie.
It's transparently stupid. The argument with with Keles is she
didn't get a lawyer. She didn't file a suit, right? She wasn't
filing motions. She didn't actually do the thing she said she
was going to do. Pixie literally did a fundraiser. then literally
did the thing she said she was going to use that money for. What
is confusing? What is weird? What is fraudulent? What is strange
about that?
Yeah. I don't know. I don't know. But what about the frolicking?
The frolicking here being going to law.
I think we're done with this.
Yeah. I think that is that
I think we're good with all of it.
should be easy narrative. It's actually the same thing as Fentes,
right? It's about the story. It's not about the facts. It's not
about what's not a good debater. It isn't because Ben Shapiro
is wrong about, you know, the Holocaust numbers. Whole cultural
movement behind Fuentes that isn't there behind Shapiro at all.
this an entire career, like more than a decade of streaming out
of making himself the victim who's been betrayed by anybody who
ever wrongs him, right?
Can't she just show how her money was spent and shut them up?
Why? Wait, why does she have to show how her money karate Moses
to file a lawsuit? She said, "I'm raising funds and I'm going
to file a lawsuit." Do you understand how now that she's filed
like it's like, "I'm raising money. I'm taking donations to bake
the world's largest cake and then I baked the world's largest
cake and you go, "Wait, where did you spend the money?" It's
like, "Well, I took the money to do a thing. I did the thing.
Who's
Where who is the wronged party here? You guys are doing the meme."
Okay.
Isn't there somebody you forgot to ask? DG screeching in a corner.
Um, can you show receipts for all of this? Can you show receipts
for all of this, please?
I thought the claim was it was being the
What is the where where who made this claim now? Karate Moses
that third parties are covering the whole case.
Regardless, that that would be like bad. I don't know if you
could get mad at her for that. She said, "I'm I'm taking donations
to help me fund this legal case." And then she filed a legal
case. Right. If somebody swoop so if somebody sweeped in after
that swooped in swooped in after that to pay for it. I don't
know if she gives that money back. She's literally rendering
the service she asked for. You might you might be able to argue
she should. I guess
he just keeps saying her parents are rich. Why couldn't she fund
raise if her parents are rich?
I totally no idea. No
Can we talk again about how hard Cyber won, by the way?
I can't believe how hard Cyber won
He started talking about this stuff. This is very, very funny.
Bro, 50K don't buy you all of that.
Come on. No, it doesn't.
It doesn't at all. I have no idea how she's paying for it at
this point.
Nobody is nobody who disagrees is contending with the argument
I gave.
He's paying them an exposure. I don't know if anybody wants to
be exposed to
Just Hold on. What is this?
>> Okay. All right.
All right.
I mean, her family is probably wealthy. She's like a professional
student and was living in Miami.
Bro, do you guys
I don't know.
You know, the US government will just let you like go to school
for like a long time, right? Like there's a there's a very easy
track where you just go to school.
Like that is it's very easy in your country to do that. Just
saying.
Not anymore. I don't know.
Used to be. Oh, maybe it's not a big deal.
Okay.